horror movies might be filled with
frights but they're usually pretty fun
to watch to every now and again however
there comes along a scary movie that's
so disturbing it's hard to justify ever
sitting through it again from extreme
gore to the true emotional torment of
audiences these are the movies you'll
want to opt-out of revisiting after the
first run as always beware the spoilers
the sacrament loosely based on true
events the sacrament is excruciating ly
tense and takes the story and it's
characters to some incredibly dark
places the faux documentary features
three reporters investigating a new
religious movement in Africa and the
climax depicts the ritual self-sacrifice
of the cult members which does not
flinch from a single moment of the pain
confusion and fear they experience it
gets particularly difficult to watch
when one of the reporters is tied down
by his sister and forced to participate
in the ritual with her in terms of craft
the sacrament probably is an incredibly
well done movie but once you've watched
the film and know the places it will
take you to it's almost impossible to
watch again martyrs the torture Horrors
sub-genre hit a new benchmark with
martyrs the French film features
characters experiencing every kind of
agony imaginable from suffering intense
beatings to being flayed alive and it's
the existential justification for this
cycle of sinister acts that's really
hard to bear the tormentors are
attempting to gain knowledge of the
afterlife by turning their subjects into
martyrs who are abused into
transcendence and after so much anguish
and gruesome violence audiences are
ultimately left to wonder what the
experience revealed if anything it's an
experience to watch this movie unfold
but it's also an exhausting one for sure
funny games sometimes bad things happen
to good people and there's no rhyme or
reason to it funny games is a story
about this very idea to sociopathic
youths Peter and Paul staged a physical
and emotional assault on a family in
their own home bones are broken lives
are ended a dog goes to doggy heaven and
all of this is done in service of a sick
game being played by the boys there is
no backstory between the family and the
men torturing them it's not a revenge
scheme and there is no plot twist
revealing the boys to be the abandoned
children of the mother or the father
Peter and Paul simply show up commit
countless atrocities and then move
on to the next family funny games might
be tremendously made but it is a
horrifying film that presents sick joy
and senseless violence and probably
won't leave you reaching for the DVD
again anytime soon the invitation even
without its twist ending the invitation
would be uncomfortable to sit through a
second time the film sets out to put the
nuance of interactions between lapsed
friends under a microscope through a few
hours spent at a tense dinner party it
analyzes the minut intricacies of every
awkward exchange between characters and
it explores the efforts people will go
to to save face and stifle survival
instincts when cordial social
interactions go to places they shouldn't
or don't you guys think this is a little
bit weird furthermore it's a stunning
meditation on grief and what people will
do to cope with loss these themes are
explored very nicely but they're so
heavy that a second viewing is likely
out of the question for most moviegoers
and this is all before the film's third
act which features the host couple
trying to snuff out all their friends
and then off themselves in the name of a
mysterious spiritual group they've
joined all at all it's an immaculate
film that is probably best left alone
after a single viewing lake mungo there
are points at which lake mungo hardly
feels like a horror film the imitation
documentary plays out as a look into how
the death of a loved one can devastate
the people around them over time there
are supernatural elements to the film
and some great frights to be had but
their comparatively sparse across the
movies hour-and-a-half running time
those scares aren't what will keep
viewers from coming back for a second
viewing though that falls entirely on
the subject matter by staging the film
is a documentary with no well-known
actors to lower the audience's
suspension of disbelief
director Joel Anderson amplifies the
emotional devastation the Palmer family
experiences after the loss of their
daughter Alice and that plays directly
into the supernatural aspects of the
plot - lake mungo is a superb film but
one that deals with some very heavy
subject matter and would be very hard to
sit through a second time audition
Takashi Nikkei has released over 100
films and he could probably go on to
direct 100 more with not one of them
earning the reputation that audition has
it's the story of a widower who at the
urging of his son connects with a young
woman named Asami as their romance
develops it becomes clear that there's
more to her than she lets on suspicions
build slowly towards the film's bloody
climax which features a horrific scene
of torture and immunity
Masami sadistically keeps alive in a bag
other films featuring torture might try
to shock the audience with a wide array
of methods but Myka instead pairs it
down to one excruciating ly simple
prolonged moment of pain audition as a
masterpiece no doubt about it
and it's absolutely worth seen but it's
still a hard movie to get through the
first time around and knowing what the
end holds will not make rewatching it
any easier thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to